hey it's thankful thursday and i believe
that it's important to thank the people
and companies who have had an impact on
your life on your business because you
can't do this all alone you need help
you need people to lift you up and
support you and so I make these videos
once a week to thank the people in my
life for having an impact and I hope
you'll reach out to your contacts and
thank them just give them some
recognition so today i want to thank
sage software and sage they make
accounting software and you may think
sage accounting software why why are you
thinking them there used to be a client
and I did some social media work with
them and I haven't talked to them for a
while in a recent touch base and have
been so impressed with what they're
doing on social media most companies
they blast out coupon codes and
marketing and we just launched our new
product everybody come and buy it and as
a result you get zero engagement because
nobody cares about that stuff that's not
what social media is all about and sage
these guys get it you go to sages page
they're talking about they recognize
their customer who just got in the whole
foods and they're tweeting pictures
about them they're recognizing people on
their team who had a birthday and
they're showcasing what they did to
their cubicle of the company they're
sharing inspirational quotes they're
sharing articles that have nothing to do
with accounting but will help
entrepreneurs grow their businesses
they're trying to be a resource this is
what's important about social media
you're not out there just broadcasting
and selling the point of social media is
to build relationships with customers
and these guys they actually care about
their customers imagine that a big
company that actually cares about their
customers now I'm fortunate to work with
a number of different big brands who
have that same mindset and sing
philosophy and I work with them other
campaigns but most companies aren't like
that and it's so refreshing to see a
company like sage stepping up and doing
it and and bucking a trend and I'm sure
whoever is running those campaigns that
are facing you know internal criticism
or external criticism to say hey this
isn't how you supposed to do it but
they're getting results and building a
strong community and that's what social
media is all about so Thank You sage for
your leadership and inspiration and for
helping the entrepreneur community and
for all of you watching take five
minutes today to thank somebody who's
had an impact on your business on your
life somehow send an email write a note
take somebody at the coffee make a video
if you want to doesn't have to be
complex just say thank you they'll feel
better you'll feel better and you
brighten everybody's day believe you
guys like this video thumbs up below if
you want to support me click on the
support link in the description and
leave a comment I'd love to hear from
you thank you so much see you soon